yes I can hear you all right
cool I think I was getting what that
last guy was talking
about um but I think it really depends
on how you look at the verse y'all were
pulling up if you could pull it up
again because uh we we probably agree
that God has multiple meanings
right
no no
no um
really really
really so you think God has one meaning
and it can't mean anything
else the word God here is Theos are
demons Gods it's only one of those no
demons are not Gods I'm pretty sure in
the scriptures that says that show
me I can't show
you I I don't have all the verses by
memory but I know bro that God has
multiple meaning there's not a single
verse that says that demons are Gods ma
however let me um but it in the PS that
says we are Gods throw you an olive an
olive
branch so if you're talking about that
there's a different contexts in which um
the word God is used sure there's
different contexts in which the word God
is used and
applied um here we're talking about in
in John 1
in John one right
here
yep and it says in the beginning was the
word and the Word was with God and the
Word was God what does that mean I think
it it's saying that the word was divine
exactly yeah I agree with that okay do
you believe that the word was created I
think so yeah okay because if you think
about how we it just doesn't exist we
have to speak right no that's that's not
the same thing it's not an audible it's
a person it's talking about how he it's
a
person so in verse
three it says this
and I don't know how this is what
happens when you guys you know reject
the Trinity but you know we find
problems with clear verses yeah go ahead
all things were made through
him do you agree with that verse with
that first statement yeah yeah okay all
things not some things not one thing all
things were made through
him and without him was not anything
made that was
made so everything that was made
anything that ever began to
exist came into existence through him
through the word
Jesus we agree so far yep so if all
things came into existence through him
and there wasn't not one thing that was
made without him that has been made then
this means that he himself could not
have been made he had to always be do
you
agree
um I want to say yes but I I just I
don't know if I could make that leap
it's not a leap it's the text see
this is the problem that I have with a
thing I wouldn't say God's word is a
thing no worries this is the problem
that you guys that you guys come
to when you reject the Trinity
bro and you reject the deity of Christ
you believe he's
created you run into
this and
plain simple clear
sentences for some reason all of a
sudden doesn't make sense to you guys
you guys can't handle plain clear
verses see in your in your heart and
your mind you you want to in your mind
you're like yeah logically that makes
perfect sense however H I don't know if
I want to just say that yet because of
my position that I have right but
logically common sensibly
it's right freaking there that's what it
says so how about this how about
together we forget our
positions we forget our presuppositions
what we've like believed before we came
on this
stream we kick that to the curb and we
just allow the scripture to speak and
whatever the scripture says that's what
we fix our minds to we agree sure okay I
think just real quick before we get into
it um maybe we could like Define Trinity
how you see that well first before we do
it do that because that's the more
that's the more complex thing this is
the simple part this right here if if
you can if we can demonstrate that we
can agree with clear texts of the
scripture then the rest will follow we
can explain Trinity we can break that
stuff down all that we can do that but
first I need to see so does God's word
depend on God the
Father there's an inter right let's
let's one step at a time thank you
sweetheart one step at a time can we see
here that the word
here couldn't have been created since
everything was created through him
anything that came to be came to be
through him which means he had to always
be already can we agree with that with
what the text says if by things you mean
other things that aren't Divine then
yeah I would say
yes by things it says okay like if you
meant but the
Earth the ocean I would say brother
brother anything made you see how it
says yeah God's not made exactly so God
is not in this category because God has
always
been right but anything made came was
made through the word I see I think I
see it
now without him was not anything made
that was
made so from that you're getting it's
uncreated
exactly which mean it's Eternal back
exactly which would also mean okay yeah
you got it I mean you got it all
right thank you Holy Spirit I thank the
holy spirit for that that's the Holy
Spirit Light Bob went off thank you bro
so this is why this is why in verse
number one it says with with the word
being Eternal and uncreated right being
Eternal means that the word is God in
the beginning was the word he was
already there the word was with God so
he's with someone who has the nature of
God which is the father and the word
himself was God as
well and when it says word that's Jesus
that's it ex you got
it all right yeah I understand it thank
you bro appreciate it of course of
course anytime man any time so guys
that's all it takes man just letting the
Holy Spirit work
because that wasn't
me that wasn't me
that wasn't me that was the that was the
spirit of the most high God that allowed
it to
click wasn't me I I I literally said the
same I said the same thing nothing I
said changed that wasn't
me all got time for a few
more
and that's that's that's it for me
if you guys have been enjoying this man
make sure you guys hit the like button
we got 2,800 people watching on
YouTube make sure you guys go ahead and
hit the like button it helps the live in
the algorithm so please go ahead and
support the live that way by hitting the
like
button um life or like this is
trinitarian live never
mind uh let me see here you may
Oh Glory to God he said you made the
Trinity make the most sense ever God
logic glory to God
guys how about a song
Break I need a what is the inil break
that's what I
need that's I need a what is the inil
break what is the NGO break
biblical Unitarian how you doing good
good how you doing I'm all
right you believe Jesus is created
what's that you believe Jesus is Jesus
is created I do yeah and what verse
tells you that Matthew
118 all
right and the reason why is you'll never
find the son back in the Old Testament
doing anything alive around the throne
worshiped nothing he's not there oh
okay all right so Matthew 1:18 it says
now the birth of Jesus Christ took place
in this way when his mother Mary had
been betr to Joseph before they came
together she was found to be with child
from the Holy Spirit so you're saying
that this is when Jesus was created he
didn't exist prior to his birth
correct he was conceived in the womb of
his
mother right and before this he didn't
exist no that's why you won't find him
in the Old Testament worshiped honored
or doing anything I disagree with that
but we'll we'll get to that in a second
so um and you believe in the you said
you're a Biblical Unitarian so you
believe in both Old and New Testament is
that right correct okay
so when it says that everything is
created through Jesus Heaven and Earth
Thrones invisible principalities rulers
etc etc all things are made through him
and for him in Colossians One how can
all things be created through Jesus if
he didn't exist yet well those are just
positions of power in Colossians those
are dispositions they're they're just
positions of power whether they be
Thrones dominions rulers and authorities
very very them yes he did because he's
establishing his
church yeah okay so it says that he
created the heavens and the Earth in
that verse right no it says Thrones
dominions rulers and authorities these
are positions of power okay let's see
doesn't say the heavens and the Earth it
says all things whether they be Thrones
dominions rulers and authorities
okay that's why Paul uses the weather
term because it's a choice between
Alternatives whether they be Thrones
dominions rulers and authorities gotcha
it says for by him all things were
created in heaven and on
earth right in heaven there's Thrones
dominions rulers and authorities he
created it all yeah Angelic structures
to run the church not not just to run
the church he created the heavens and
the earth and the authorities within
them no it doesn't say he created the
heavens he says all things were created
in heaven and on Earth visible whether
they be Thrones dominions rulers and
authorities so in heaven there's Thrones
there's dominions there's rulers and
authorities but it doesn't say he
created the heavens there it it it does
it literally is saying that he created
the heavens and all that's in them where
does it say that say for by him all
things were created is heaven a thing
things in Heaven and Earth is is heaven
a thing and Earth yeah but Paul tells
you whether they be Thrones dominions
rulers all of it yeah he goes into
detail
so all of so for by him all things were
created heaven and Earth are things that
were created right no the list is there
whether they be Thrones dominions wait
wait wait brother are Heaven and the is
the Heaven and the Earth things that
were created yeah but that's not the
things that were created here but it
says for him by by him all things were
created yeah so Heaven and Earth would
be a thing created no in Heaven and
Earth the Thrones dominions rulers and
authorities are the things created both
in heaven and earth this is tough me
that's tough okay because in the Old
Testament you'll only find God the
father being called The Creator you
never find the son back there at all
ever what about The Spirit Well the
spirit is the spirit of the father is he
the father it's the it's the power in
presence of the father is he the father
well again it's kind of like the Rays of
the Sun come from the Sun they're
they're the same thing but distinct
because it's the power and presence of
the father are the raised the son well
technically that you could I got burned
by the sun today but it's not the ball
up in the sky right but are the Rays the
sun uh yes they proceed from the Sun are
they the son no just like the holy
spirit is not literally the father right
well the holy spirit is not the father
in totality it's the power and presence
of the father so the holy spirit is not
the father no it is it's his power and
presence you just said he I'm confused
no because when I when I refer to the
father I refer to the father in his
totality his word his wisdom his fruit
is everything but oh you believe the
word is the father as well yes yes I do
interesting you're an interesting
Unitarian okay all right so here in uh
Hebrews one you agree that uh the
father's speaking of the son in these
verses no there's no he says in the
Greek but who's speaking the psalmist is
speaking okay when it said okay let's
actually pull this up in the Greek can
you pull up the RSV RSV translation hold
I'm I'm gonna bring up the Greek because
you said it's in the Greek so let's go
to the Greek it's not in the Greek yeah
there's no he says that's added I got
you it says but of the son and then
starts quoting right right that's the
that's quoting the psalmist yeah but but
of the son who's the one that's speaking
the psalmist they're quoting the
psalmist prophecy and now they're a
planet but who but who are they
attributing the words of the psalmist to
they're the psalmist is speaking about
the son okay let's like for example um
it says here for to which of the Angels
did God ever say you are my son today
have begotten you is that is that words
of the
psalmist for which Angel did God ever
say is and then the psalmist ends and
says you are my son that's the father
there but that's the psalmist speaking
though isn't it no for which Angel did
God ever say that's a psalmist and then
God the father says you are my son this
this is Hebrews this is the writer of
Hebrews saying this no this is writer of
Hebrews quoting the psalmist back in
Psalm yeah he quotes he quotes the psalm
when he when right here this is the part
he quotes the psalm do you agree yeah
but it's but it's right here right here
it's the writer of Hebrews right now
right correct okay so the writer of
Hebrews says for to which of the Angels
did God ever say and then he quotes the
psalmist right yeah but it's actually
God saying you are my boom you got it he
quotes the psalmist but attributes the
words of the psalmist to God because
that's God speaking through the psalmist
right no verse five is the psalmist
saying but which Angel did God ever say
and then right here God is speaking
where where in the psalm because we know
where this is coming from yeah right
this is this is uh that's the father
speaking this is Psalm 27 right that's
the psalm speak that's the father
speaking yes no I need you I need you to
like listen so that you know what I'm
asking okay right here for to which of
the Angels did God ever say these words
are these the words of the psalmist or
the author of Hebrews psalmist the
author of the author of Hebrews is
quoting the psalmist who spoke okay so
where in the Psalms can you show me
where in the Psalms does the psalmist
say for to which of the Angels did God
ever say yeah it's back in I think it's
back in Psalm 8 okay so okay Psalm 8 I
believe
so Psalm 8 it's actually I think it's
quoting Psalm 27 it's quotings exactly
it's quoting Psalm 27 bro yeah so Psalm
so so we okay so Psalm 27
yeah and he quotes it I'll decree the
Lord said to me you are my son today
I've begotten you right that's what he
that's what he quotes right here right y
that's that's the father speaking
exactly got you y now listen to my
question please because I feel like
you're I don't know if you're getting it
or if you're ignoring it these words
right here you see the highlighted part
yeah whose words are those I just said
it's the psalmist speaking where dides
the psalmist say this that's the quote
for which Angel did he ever say did no
no where does the psalmist say where in
the Psalms does it say for to which of
the Angels did God ever say where does
it say this these words in the Psalms in
the in the psalm yeah um I I think it's
in Psalm 120 I believe brother we're in
the psalm that he's quoting I know but
Psalm to there's multiple Psalms Hebrews
one uh takes multiple Psalm I know
brother man this is come on man this you
gotta be kidding me I know that we know
that there's multiple passages in the
Psalms that the writer of Hebrews is
quoting can we agree that the writer of
Hebrews be before he quotes the psalm
these are his words right yes thank you
these so starting at verse five these
aren't the words of the psalmist yet
these are the writers of Hebrew this is
the words of the writer of Hebrews then
he quotes the psalm right well who's
actually speaking here that's my
question to you we we'll get there in a
second first let's understand what we're
looking at can we agree that that first
it's the writer of Hebrews that's
speaking then he quotes the psalm
right I believe like I said I believe
that says for which Angel did he ever
say I believe that's actually a quote
from the uh the Psalms in the Old
Testament all right show me where I
believe I'm trying to find it I believe
that's that's how I would read it if
it's not correct then that I'm certainly
open to being wrong but that's how I
would see it which Angel did God ever
say
yeah yeah take your time I'm find that
translation no trust me take take your
time bro because I'm second
Samuel yeah second well it says uh 2
Samuel
7:14 it says I will proclaim the decree
of the Lord he said you are my son today
have begotten that's not what I'm
looking for um so I I would see this as
because we're we're shown back in the
Old Testament God will say which Angel
did God ever say you are my son right
that's that's what the psalmist was
stating that's where does the psalmist
say this uh well he in the Old Testament
he says uh which Angel did God ever say
right back in the S he doesn't say that
you're saying see in the Old Testament
does God ever say you are my uh does
does it say it doesn't exist bro you
sure yeah okay let's see here did God uh
which Angel did God ever say so back in
the Old Testament where does it
State um it
state to which
Angel did God of state and if it's not
there then um then then I then I I just
I would have to assume that that would
be like you said the book The the author
of Hebrews
right but I've always understood it to
be the
um it says which Angel did God ever say
it's SEC it's Psalm 27 and 2 Samuel uh
we know so so I would take it then I
would take it as the the the author of
Hebrews then very good okay now we can
continue so the author of Hebrews
here yeah he says for to which of the
Angels did God ever say then he quotes
the psalmist
here he's quoting the
psalmist who God is speaking through
right right so these are God's words
through the psalmist can we
agree uh well I would see yeah he's
quoting the psalmist but these are God's
words right yes exactly boom all right
so continuing or again so he quotes
another Psalm or Deuteronomy he also
quotes and so he's quoting the psalmist
correct but these are God's words
through the psalmist right I will be a
father exactly right that's exactly
right okay then again and again when he
brings the first born into the world he
says let all God's angels worship him
correct right so these are again he's
quoting the psalmist but these are God's
words through the psalmist correct of
the angels He said yes same thing he
makes his angels winds and his ministers
a flame of fire MH but of the sun now
you're saying in the Greek it doesn't
say he says but no worries continuing
the same context and theme it says but
of the son then he quotes the psalmist
still attributing to God's words though
through the psalmist right correct but
like I was saying I was trying to pull
up the RSV there is no there's no
vocative or God in the in the Hebrew or
the Greek that's my there's no God if
you pull up RSV there's a footnote says
or God Is Thy Throne so there is no the
oh God is an addition that that that was
not there it's okay brother you don't
it's okay that's not my contention right
now I although I disagree but that's not
my sir can I show you I know I know what
you're talking about that that doesn't
matter to me that's not my contention
okay my my thing is is just making sure
that we see that this is the father
speaking of the son no I I disagree with
that I disagree with that ah and father
speaking to the son because there's no
he says see there was he says up top but
there is no see he says here that's
added okay I would not I would see it as
the author is quoting the psalmist just
like you said all the way through but
and they stop and all the way through
let's do this again yeah all the way
through whose words are the are the
psalmist are the words of the psalmist
being attributed to they do attribute to
the father okay when does that change
because when it says he says notice
again he says and again he says then it
says but Unto the Sun okay let me ask
you this let me ask you this if I said
um what's your name by the way if you
don't mind me ask CM I'm just go by CM C
CM CM oh CM okay CM okay if I said um
you know uh CM CM talks about um CM
talks about his Co his his his
coworker right he talks about his
coworker um and his
he says uh you know to to which or if I
say to which of of cm's co-workers did
he ever say um you're my son you know
today I've begotten you and then I say
and again to again um to uh to to his
co-workers he says um you guys need to
listen to my son when he comes into
work right um and then I say again um
you know of the co-workers he uh CM says
you know they will get paid by the hour
but my son gets paid more than them
right and then I continue and I say but
of the
Sun but of the
sun you are to take and inherit the
business um the co-workers will listen
to you you are the foundation by which I
built all
this who am I speaking to
well you're speaking to the son right
you're speaking to the co whatever but
my point sir is there's no he says in
the Greek though but whose words am I
applying that to when I say but of but
of his son but of his son you're
applying it about the son yeah but whose
words uh who you're speaking on behalf
of exactly yeah so even though I never
said but of the son CM says I didn't
have to continue that I didn't have to
say
but of the son CM says for you to
understand that I'm still continuing to
quote
CM well because all throughout before
I've been quoting cm and showing the
difference of how CM thinks about his
co-workers versus his son and then I
finally get to the part where of the son
this is what cm is is saying even though
I don't say see him says get what I'm
saying yeah I get what you're saying but
the problem is is there there I I
understand your logic but that's with
the he says and again he says and again
he says they shift over and they say but
Unto the Sun so there is no he says
there there is the only the only shift
is who the father is now talking to yeah
I I I don't believe it's God the Father
speaking to the son in that passage I
just don't okay because it doesn't work
if you if you just read it if you just
read it contextually it just doesn't
work I got you so contextually you was
able to understand that the words that I
was quoting were
cm's words to his son even though I
didn't say but of the son CM says yes
but again but here it doesn't work
though no because because we're prefaced
with he says he says of the angels He
says and then we go down and we're
assuming he see he's speaking to the son
but it doesn't say he
says beautiful point but I want so
because of the context you can see that
he the father's still speaking but not
of the Angels anymore but of his son now
right no I would see it as a psalmist or
planet to the Sun now I wouldn't see the
father speaking here okay well that's as
far as we can get man can I show you one
thing though can I ask you one thing I'm
not interested because I feel like
you're being dishonest here I'm not
interested you lo you lost my interest
here I'm not being dishonest I'm just
you know when I wanted to show you in
Hebrews 18 it's not that's fine or God
Is Thy Throne thank you thank you for
coming okay thanks